shadow of Mordor pushes out some free
dlc called power of shadow which gives
you the option to play as the game's
antagonist the black hand putting on
this sweet looking skin isn't just the
only thing you can look forward to
playing as the black hand also brings
you three epic runes for each of the
three weapons let's take a look the
elven grace rune beefs up your D cutting
down all damage taken from melee hits by
hack great the ascendant rune offers
some double focus time for some longer
slo-mo ranged arrow strikes sweet and
then lastly and my personal fave there's
the one with nature room which makes you
immune to all poison attacks from
captains or ghouls yay no more OD'ing
huh so let's put this to the test I'm
picking the Warchief stuck oogah because
this piece of likes to dish out poisoned
arrows and their heels the most
beautiful of all
all right just hit me with a poisoned
arrow god damn you're so weird oh yeah I
am immune you idiot
God should I dominate or kill I was
that is what you can look forward to
ladies and gentlemen and when you try
out your new Black Hand suit do not
forget to share some of your favorite
Mordor moments with the custom photo
mode here are some of my hot pics of the
letter enjoy every time I do it makes me
laugh
what am i I get so red when I cut off
every off hand and this is where I grew
up
I think autumn came and ate it up I
never knew that
oh we learn about what it felt bad area
how shadow girl I think there's a little
shadow
oh yeah oh yeah believe in
you